what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here John Humphrey over here we're gonna
watch the trailer for the prequel to 13
hours 12 another January war movie
January caliber pun family man 19 men
attacked our country
now do you love your family and leaving
when we go to war I had two hours I'll
be really quick not a chance I'm holding
right here you come back to me it's
gonna be only a week
[Music]
[Music]
teaming up the general of the Northern
Alliance know nothing about general you
show me exactly where we're gonna put
the mountains we take horses before in
spring I can't order anyone to do this
you want to surrender your finger on the
trigger
no playbook here we have to write
themselves
[Music]
really ask our time if you die that's a
letter you and your wife for now what
she wrote
[Music]
[Music]
12 strong the Declassified true story of
the horse soldiers sad shop
automatically when I hear this January
release that's the way I am the other
aspect to me though it feels like this
could work as a great blend of what I
think both audiences would want you got
really good actors really great Michael
Shannon and Chris Hemsworth and Michael
Pena are all strong actors yeah and even
like David Fichtner and Rob Riggle yeah
real veteran and stuff like there are a
lot of more faces than I wasn't even
expecting to see in this but then it's
also produced by Jerry Bruckheimer hose
no did you like action movies hey well
and this looks like it certainly has a
lot of intense action sequence yeah I'm
thinking that this might be captured a
little more on the spectrum of an action
film it just feels that way
it's like you got the beats of what the
who these soldiers are a lot of the
dialogue sounds like very reminiscent of
other war films we've already seen yeah
you know I don't want to say cliche
because I've in a way by saying that I
feel like it sounds insulting to the
actual soldiers who fought in the war
yeah but there are common themes that we
explore in films like this yeah and anis
you know war movies change over
generations and stuff and so you know
the voice of current war movies now is
gonna be kind of similar to the other
ones I feel like these are hard
conflicts because this is this is a
situation that the ripples are still you
know oh yeah floating out want to do
that in a way that's not just super
jingoistic or something that's not just
rah-rah you know you want to just depict
the situation at hand the triumphs of
the human spirit yeah yes I just think
there it'll probably have both in terms
of even if it feels a little cliche in
terms of just this film format to say
cool action scene sounds gripping
gripping gripping action scenes they're
like there's gonna be an emotional
intensity to it the cast is that they
have assembled here I think you can get
both a pretty good drama with some
pretty gripping action scenes combined
into one that doesn't the layout be one
of the best war films ever made and
entertaining and
at times moving one at best yeah well
when I see this you know it doesn't look
like crappy January I'm almost yeah yeah
maybe I'm sort of like what time of year
would you want to put this out during
and and sort of January might be a nice
time because there's not really anything
specific associated yeah so you know if
it doesn't have a particular place in
the summer because it looks a bit too
Reedy and intense for summer yeah you
know in comparison to level of action
there isn't it's not Christmas movies
the new year seems like a time and place
to do it the balance of intense war
violence and it does look like a story
that I'm interested to see these dudes
on horseback fighting tanks and stuff
yeah that's sort of the first soldiers
to go overseas
yeah after 9/11 my only hope for movies
like these that they just handle the
situation with care because there's a
lot of anticipate it is there I take it
it's based on a true story based on a
true story to classify us I mean you
can't just make it like cool action no
cool war action because this the events
are like what only fifty sixteen years
ago yeah you can't make it war porn like
it said from producer Jerry Bruckheimer
who brews Black Hawk Down and it has to
I feel like has to be more on that
spectrum where it's like gritty intense
you can't help but go it's pretty cool
actually but it's also Connor disturbing
and realistic you know yeah totally good
for Chris Hemsworth yeah I mean he's a
he's a gripping leading man to I don't
where he go he gets a big movie outside
of Thor yeah yeah maybe Thor will help
him switch over and do a more comedic
space yeah yeah I mean not this this
well that in any way shape or form I
like the guys range that's the thing is
is you know of all the Hemsworth this
even here I'm like do you you look
really compelling yeah alright guys well
thanks for tuning in you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell follow ad at John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram so I
got a patreon become a patron eject
today